welcome to a fire ship channel update
for September 2019
I want to start by saying thank you to
everybody because the channel just
recently surpassed two hundred thousand
subscribers which is a number I never
would have expected to reach writing
code and creating content are both
activities that commonly lead to burnout
but I'm extremely lucky to have a
community that provides positive
feedback that keeps me motivated to make
more and more videos so again thank you
for that now the main reason I wanted to
make this update was to let you know the
direction of the content for the next
couple months
my number one priority is finishing up
an angular fire based course that is
based on the app that you're seeing here
in the screen my first attempt at
developing this course didn't go too
well the first app that I built
ended up being overly complex and didn't
really showcase the best things that
angular has to offer the new version of
the course eases angular material and
the cdk to build a drag and drop Trello
style board project management app it's
fully integrated with firebase
authentication features for progressive
Web Apps and server-side rendering with
angular Universal the app itself allows
you to create these things called boards
and then each board has its own
integrated list that can be sorted and
the boards themselves can be sorted as
well and of course all this data stays
in sync with firestore the course is
designed for intermediate level or
experienced developers but it will start
with an hour-long session geared
specifically towards angular basics and
the basic section will be available for
free while the more advanced sections
will be available to pro members and it
should be released later this week maybe
next week at the very latest
I'll post updates on slack when I'm more
confident on the release date then after
this course is released I plan to do a
higher frequency of videos on YouTube
which will include the continuation of
the JavaScript course and the next video
in that series will be about JavaScript
objects and then I have a massive list
of firebase integration videos where we
take a feature and then build it into a
front-end framework like angular
flutters felt etc basically the same
type of content you've been seen on my
channel from day one and speaking of
firebase firebase summit is coming up at
the end of the month and I'm pretty sure
firebase is going to announce some cool
stuff there I don't work for Google so
that's purely speculation on my part but
they have some pretty awesome stuff in
the works that you'll want to keep an
eye on
I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up
there keep an eye on slack for an update
on the angular chorus and then you can
expect a lot more content in the coming
months thanks again everybody and I will
talk to you soon
[Music]